[музыка]
да да и не только в россии но конечно
бывшие советские советского союза да
очень много людей не только в украине но
в казахстане много-много странах говорят
по-русски и это один из
международные на самые важные нежные
международный языка в мире
испанский рабский я когда я покажу когда
я слышал был счастлив этой это время до
10 лет назад я много сосредоточился на
русском языке к сожалению я очень долго
не занимаюсь русского русском языке
когда я был в украине 2 раз там я
попробовал один нож skype вообще слышишь
по-русски и поэтому к сожалению точности
русского языка нуждается
усилия и когда очень долго я не
занимаюсь русском языке конечно будет
забивать сов и сделать много ошибки
когда меня это не важно я я я покажу
людей
что я сейчас говорю с трудностей но все
равно для меня это
это огромное удовольствие каждый раз
когда я могу говорить по-русски и это
нисколько не мешает нашей коммуникации я
прекрасно вас понимаю поэтому я тоже
закрою что ошибок бояться не нужно они
будут без них нельзя а но это никак не
должно препятствовать общению
да и даже если я буду сосредоточиться на
русском языке
я боюсь я не боюсь но я знаю что я
никогда не будет говорить дсп с ошибками
никогда-никогда
и по-английский я много лет занимала
международный бизнеса за людьми из из
швеции
из германии не говоря о но японцы не
является самое лучшее по английском
языке но людей из швеции в германию они
говорят очень хорошо по английски и все
равно всегда будет ошибки будет и будут
ошибки которые отражают привыкну
привычки из их родной язык конечно я
знаю здесь в канаде у нас есть сотрудник
из 1
я из россии он русский языческий
из избрал давида избившие советского
союза и он говорит прекрасно
по-английски прекрасное и он может всё
объяснить и понимаете все и говорять как
каждый обычный канадец но у него не
существует он говорит свободно обязать и
и все понимают и
и он очень но я хочу что все равно я
хотел бы если я будет сейчас сотру . на
русском языке
я будет я хочу с вами изучать чтобы я
говорю говорил бы точно потру по-русски
но все равно никогда не будете давать
без ошибки ошибками и это не важно это
не мешает меня имеет большой
удовольствием за изучение русского языка
абсолютно все зависит от вашей цели вы
же не устраивайтесь работать
переводчиком в организацию объединенных
наций до или вы не переводчик президента
вот в таком случае наверно стоит
потратить экстра усилия чтобы говорить
без ошибок я живу в америке 10 лет
изучаю английский язык с пяти лет и все
равно я уверена что я делаю большое
количество ошибок просто люди
воспитанные небо то не говорят
и русские люди тоже в своем родном языке
и допускают большое количество ошибок
конечно же не подержанных например как
допустили бы иностранцы и но
ударение значения слов и так далее язык
это что-то глубокая бездонная как не
знаю огромное команды поди надо так что
потянуть и страшного вопрос если я вам
спрошу я хочу говорить ну что я хочу
делать меньше ошибки как какой ваш
предложение как это как плейбой и
как вы можете мне помогать говорить им
чаще коми мой рецепт такой я была
порекомендовала нанять преподавателя
лучше дать человек который может
объяснить ваши ошибки или хотя бы
носители языка которые не является вашим
супругом супругой близким другом потому
что это вызывает конфликт и
и попросить с вами регулярно общаться и
записывать ваши ошибки и потом вам о них
говорить и потом на мой взгляд вам нужно
будет осознанно обращать внимание на эти
ошибки недопустимы допускаете ошибку в
падежах постоянно одно и то же то что
наши ошибки обычно одни и те же да какие
то носи закостенелые и вы сами себя
должны быть остановите сказать так стоп
а вот тут надо сделать вот так то есть
нужно осознанность на когда мы включаем
голову и постепенно перед тренируем себя
на то чтобы эту ошибку не допускать мне
то есть это такой рецепт вы вы думаете
скажите мне да но управляю я не я я
понимаю русский грамматика понимаю все я
читают не я много читала я понимаю но
когда я говорил я не могу это когда
когда я говорю если я должен думаешь о
праве на уровне который я понимаю надо
поинты и по этой по этой думать я не
могу удалить это значит как развивать
весь лекции да и что вы сказали это это
это это правда я не знаю рабский
какой-либо язык я будет говорить через
интернет и каждый раз будет писать
списки мои ошибки знаешь и какими-то
и я могу читать там будет писаться и
только в списке и ноябре медаль у меня
есть есть запись этой этой дискуссии я
вижу что каждой корзине деле я делаю то
же самые ошибки и каждый раз у нас
сказать не это не так это так и каждый
следующая лекция
сервиса дискуссии урок я буду сделать то
же самое хотя я знаю хотя она меня
из правильно исправно никакой и как как
это как это сказать а мне flex так как
это исправить
стив но мне кажется нельзя забывать
пропитки осознанность и повторение да то
есть хорошо второй раз сделайте ту же
ошибку 3 1 5 но на 7 вы уже сами
остановитесь и скажите не чтоб не так а
то есть какая-то вот контроль все равно
должен быть даст затем что вы говорите
ну и плюс я на самом деле согласна с
вашим методом вы говорите штук языку
нужно привыкнуть да и нужного слушать
читать чтобы это стало родным до чтобы
ваше ухо
тому поймала себя на мысли так что то не
то я говорю что-то неправильно также
абсолютная комбинация до огромного
количества слушания чтение и контроля за
собой осознанности и потом в итоге это
становится чем-то
натуральный чем-то естественным для вас
и и итоге я думаю что надо не бояться и
нога
признать что вы не бы я признаю что я не
буду говорить мы за сетками
поэтому но я тоже знаю что как вы
сказали он немножко по постепенно
постепенно у меня будет новой привычки
например
нажат самый-самый просто это корабли к
инструменту с нами свами
ими где вы потому что это это
понемножечку по-другому окей и и а это
сложно но с вами из нами и это это 100 и
там будет на мой мозг фразы которые
звучат натурально и количество этой
фразы это натуральные фразы внутри кого
есть там правильно конструкции
количество будет по немножку увеличивать
или я думаю что рей конечно надо
отметить надо столбик как что-то
попробую и
исправлять или вы должны найти то что
случится в физике но сложного есть
сложность поэтому не надо слишком
беспокоиться нужно понимать над чем
работать да ведь чуть мужа же не знает
что он делает ошибку простить вам или
спросить вас правильно будет просить вас
но у меня по налогу на си студенты
говорят спросить вам если я не скажу что
это не верно они об этом не узнают
поэтому прелесть преподавателя в том что
он может указать на то над чем работать
да и в принципе все таки
но надеюсь что следующий раз когда мы
будет году будем говорить по-русски я
могу понемножку получить вы говорите
по-русски может стать еще лучше да но
еще равно я думаю что ваши я видел ваши
каналы очень хорошо очень мотивирует это
самый ваши спасибо большое спасибо очень
приятно подобрав
[музыка]